bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
semaine d'actualité locale sur tv fil 78
voici les titres de ce lundi 18 mai
ouverture de la semaine de
l'environnement attrape expositions
ateliers pour apprendre les bons gestes
et changer ses habitudes nous en
parlerons avec thomas sûrs d'y adjoint
au maire invité du journal le bassin de
latone le château de versailles reprend
vie après deux ans de travaux le public
peut découvrir depuis ce matin le
résultat d'une rénovation unique et puis
en partenariat avec le radio sensations
nous irons tout au long de la semaine à
cannes à la rencontre des yvelinois qui
participent au festival ce soir quand un
dupuis jeune réalisateur de plaisir
l'île des loisirs à la trappe accueille
cette semaine le célèbre skipper vincent
riou avec son équipe de voile le
vainqueur du vendée globe en 2005 est en
pleine tournée des lacs
il se prépare pour le tour de france qui
débute le 3 juillet et présentent leur
trimaran on écoute vincent riou au micro
de yolaine thérèse et william l
il entend rapprocher la discipline du
grand public c'est un sport qui en
général est assez méconnu parce qu'il ya
plein de disciplines dans la voile c'est
un sport qui est très vaste et l'idée
l'idée de ce petit bateau transportable
qu'on peut emmener partout sur le
littoral ou à l'intérieur des terres
c'est justement de faire des régates des
courses à la voile très très proche du
public et de pouvoir de pouvoir amener
un visuel vers le grand public et à la
fin de cette édition nous reparlerons
sport avec la visite des joueurs du psg
handball à saint quentin en yvelines et
dans quelques jours se tiendra la
première semaine européenne du
développement durable du 30 mai au 5
juin bonnes pratiques de consommation
biodiversité également à l'honneur la
ville de trappes devance l'appel en
lançant aujourd'hui sa semaine de
l'environnement et pour en parler sur ce
plateau thomas hardy bonsoir vous êtes
adjoint au maire de trappes en charge de
ces différentes questions on va évoquer
le programme la finalité de ce rendez
vous qui a donc débuté aujourd'hui avec
notamment des expositions vous venez de
le voir tout d'abord on va préciser
qu'il y à de nombreux acteurs de
mobiliser associations étudiants conseil
des jeunes
et puis principalement les bailleurs
sociaux parce que ce sont eux aussi qui
sont à l'origine de
ça tout à fait c'est effectivement une
démarche partenariale que la ville de
trappes à vous souhaitez lancer pour une
réussite effectivement une vraie
dynamique collective
il a fallu effectivement que les
services municipaux soient très
sollicités très moteur sur ses actions
et donc pour ne citer que certains les
centres sociaux qui sont vraiment de
rennes qui draine un public sur trappe
assez consistants puis nous avons aussi
les centres de loisirs qui se sont
lancés dans l'aventuré cette année
et puis bien sûr la gestion urbaine de
proximité qui est une partie intégrante
de la rénovation urbaine
je parlais des bailleurs sociaux aussi
si le projet cette semaine existent
depuis plusieurs années sur la ville de
trappes s'ils sont associés c'est aussi
parce qu'il ya eu des constats des
choses qui ne fonctionnait pas il
fallait apprendre aux gens les
accompagnait aussi sur certaines
questions c'est pour ça alors ce que
vous dites il est fort juste mais on
avait pris conscience déjà en 2006 avant
de lancer la première rénovation urbaine
et dans le cadre de la convention de
développement social et il ya donc un
volume effectivement de la gestion
urbaine de proximité et dont il ya un
ensemble de programmes d'action qui sont
qui se place entre la ville et le
bailleur et cette convention fait vise à
accompagner les efforts engagés pour
rendre une qualité de vie à tous les
trappistes va regarder un petit peu le
programme même si le programme détaillé
on va pas forcément vous le donner ce
soir mais il est à retrouver sur le site
internet de la ville
c'est quoi ce sont des ateliers pour
donner des conseils pratiques
un petit peu partout aux quatre coins de
la ville alors vous avez effectivement
différents types de manière sensibiliser
un public déjà de manière informative
nous avons sur l'économie d'énergie
certaines choses qui seront organisés
des courts métrages notamment sur
l'environnement les débats sur le
développement durable
et puis façon aussi à sensibiliser les
écoles de manière pédagogique nous avons
des expositions qui sont mises en place
des expositions qui sont ouvertes à tous
sur l'eau les éco gestes et le tri
sélectif de manière générale sur le
thème de la nature des actions propreté
et puis on citera certainement le rallye
à lille de loisirs qui est une des
actions phare mais pas que nous avons
aussi des actions artistiques notamment
des sculptures et tableaux qui seront
réalisés à partir de récupération de
déchets donc effectivement un ensemble
de palettes ouvert deux cuillerées
aux plus grands et aux images non pas
dans le conte continue à parler on voit
quelques images on va revoir les images
de l'exposition notamment peut-être une
parenthèse justement sur cet objectif
artistique finalement aussi il ya cet
atelier vous l'avez mentionné alors des
ateliers artistiques y en a plusieurs
notamment on peut citer un exemple de
partenariat avec efidis de création de
panneaux d'art de street art qui seront
ensuite mis dans les jardins de masse et
de façon aussi prendre conscience de
l'environnement qui est le nôtre de
respecter ça la nature qui nous
environne le rallye vous l'avez
mentionné au single rise déroulé ce
rallye le rallye c'est une grande
nouveauté là encore nous avons fait un
partenariat avec lise l'institut
supérieur de l'environnement dans cette
dix étudiants qui se sont impliqués sur
trois thématiques et donc trois ateliers
avec des quiz des qcm un ensemble assez
variés le périscolaire avec la fée qui
courent notamment attrapé pierre sémard
sont associés dès le départ mais c'est
ouvert à tous publics décents sociaux
notamment
et puis donc on va traiter de la
question de l'eau du vivant et de
manière on va dire une situe sur cette
belle île de loisirs l'objectif c'est de
faire naître aussi des projets peut-être
des choses qui peuvent se mettre en
place ensuite au long de l'année alors
partons de la jeunesse du projet
effectivement et et pour ne citer qu
elle il ya marie s'est alors glissé
c'est une jeune fille de trappes qui
souhaitait que la ville s'implique sur
les questions de l'environnement et donc
nous avons souhaité aussi de l'impliquer
et et partir de ce souhait que sont les
souhaits des jeunes notamment les jeunes
aussi du conseil municipal des jeunes
qui se sont impliqués de façon à
proposer des choses qui sont
intergénérationnel transgénérationnel et
l'idée c'est aussi de laisser une une
ville et puis une terre habitable pour
nos enfants on va continuer à évoquer
cette initiative attrape après ce
reportage ont visé plusieurs animations
sont proposées en lien avec les
bailleurs sociaux de la commune ce lundi
à la maison des projets en atelier
consacré à la réalisation de produits
d'entretien écologiques économiques
catherine du gâteau et le diwan pour les
images 2 cuillerées à soupe de
bicarbonate de sodium alimentaire de
l'eau chaude 2 cuillerées à soupe de
vinaigre blanc et pour parfumer quelques
gouttes d'huile essentielle
voilà la recette pour réaliser un
produit d'entretien écologiques et
économiques et les adhérents de
l'atelier sociolinguistique de trappes
présentes ce jour là ont le sentiment
d'avoir appris les choses c'est bien
beau paysage est aussi
il n'ya pas dangereux pour les enfants
voilà c'est aussi protéger
l'environnement
voilà c'est bien pour nous les petits
trucs un petit geste
on ne sait pas et on petit geste est
simplement économie de l'aja est aussi
peut nous protéger aussi d'abord un
c'est moins cher d'accord et ça
fonctionne très très très bien vous
pouvez l'utiliser pour beaucoup de
choses à la maison parce helmand pour
nettoyer la vaisselle vous pouvez à
faire les sols avec même pour les
habiles abdoulkarim ci est agent de
proximité auprès de valophis c'est lui
qui anime l'atelier
une façon aussi pour le bailleur social
d'apprendre à connaître ses locataires
valophis agir sur la commune quelques
3500 logements de but en fait c'est
surtout de pouvoir de se rapprocher d'un
effectivement à des personnes qui
viennent pas souvent faire des
réclamations
c'est par ce biais là qu'on raconte les
habitants ça c'est un atelier qui nous
permet donc à la fois donc de rencontrer
donc les habitants télé va dans un autre
en fait 1,2
ce soit non sous la gestion de l'actif
en fait toute la semaine est consacrée à
l'environnement attrape bailleurs
sociaux mais également l'association y
noue l'institut supérieur de
l'environnement sont mobilisés à cette
occasion et nous continuons à parler de
cette semaine qui s'ouvre à trappes avec
l'élu en charge des questions
d'environnement dans la commune
concrètement justement en matière
d'environnement il ya des efforts à
faire sur la commune de trappes je pense
à la gestion des déchets par exemple les
fameux bacs où il faut trier et
quelquefois les mauvais élèves qui sont
pointés du doigt s 4 ap il ya des est-ce
que tu rappes tout simplement
globalement est en mauvaise élève en
matière de tri trappe et un délai qui
s'en sort très bien
pour le dire simplement il ne fait
effectivement bâtis un parcours de tri
sélectif au sein de la ville on part de
loin mais on est arrivé quelque part où
on n'espérait pas encore forcément à
être à l'heure actuelle alors les bien
évidemment les efforts continus
aujourd'hui vous avez vu qu'on peut
traiter de la question du développement
durable par la question du tri sélectif
effectivement ça c'est important les
gestes du quotidien mais aussi par la
question de la gestion de son aîné de
l'énergie que l'on utilise chaque jour
notamment la question de l'eau sur
l'association autour de ces questions là
et ça fait partie aussi de cette
mobilisation générale au sein de la
ville il ya des efforts qui sont faits
par les services municipaux également
sur cette question d'être très de tri
d'électricité aussi alors tout à fait
alors sur la question du tri nous avons
avec 6 donc je pense que vous connaissez
bien cette société nous avons un vrai
partenariat c'est intercommunale je
crois que ça regroupe cent onze communes
presque cinq cent mille habitants et
nous avons effectivement réussi à
obtenir des résultats qui sont
fabuleuses dire que le tri se fait bien
en amont et donc ça donne des gains pour
les villes et ça c'est intéressant et
c'est dans cette démarche là que nous
sommes effectivement de façon aussi à
baisser les
on va dire tout ce qui est dépensé
inutile de faire des économies partout
donc forcément c'est peut-être là un
secteur qui peut être envisager
peut-être concernant les prochains
rendez vous aussi à venir sur la commune
mercredi 14h 17h exposition sur le
respect des espaces verts aussi ça aussi
ça fait partie des gestes importants
alors c'est ce qu'on disait au début de
ce journal effectivement ça fait partie
des gestes importants
c'est une façon aussi de s'approprier
son territoire envoyé quand on est dans
un quartier quand on a le respect de ces
lieux on a envie d'y retourner l envie
de faire jouer les enfants et ça crée
aussi une émulation je dirai au sein de
la commune
vous avez cité le mercredi le mercredi
c'est aussi un jour phare pour le
conseil municipal des jeunes parce que
il ya ce marché qui est conséquent le
marché des merisiers et chaque jeune
viendra avec des sacs de pour pour faire
une récupération de déchets in situ dans
sa robe
tout ça ça marche parce qu'il ya
l'implication des citoyens mais font six
ans que je généralise
alors c'est nécessaire et puis ça marche
ça marche sur trappe en tout cas on a
une vraie alors comme je vous disais des
petits comme aux grands sépare de deux
centres de loisirs ça parle de centres
sociaux sa part là encore des
initiatives d'école c'est par ce biais
qu'on a réussi qu'on réussira plus tard
à mobiliser un maximum de public autant
ces questions là on est sur une semaine
c'est très bien et au delà de ça après
est ce qu'il ya un suivi qui est fait
par la municipalité est ce qu'à d'autres
rendez-vous ponctuellement qui sont
alors c'est un rendez vous qui a lieu
deux fois par an déjà la semaine de
l'environnement sur trappe
c'est une démarche qui se construit
encore au delà de ça c'est tous les
gestes du quotidien et ce qui était
important et qu'on retrouve un petit peu
dans votre dans votre film c'est que on
a effectivement valophis notamment pour
ne citer qu'eux et fis dissous d'autres
sont des vrais partenaires au sein de la
ville sont des partenaires qui
s'impliquent et c'est effectivement pour
d'autres choses que des questions du
quotidien
mais on a aussi cette implication des
partenaires qui est essentiel pour
terminer cette séquence un
micro-trottoir vos gestes pour
l'environnement
vos réponses au quotidien le tri
sélectif dans la mesure du possible et
fermer le robinet quand on se brosse les
dents je serai je mangeais écologique
précédé j'essaie de réduire tous mes
déchets ou encore ouverte
je vais aussi à la déchetterie pour
on pas jeter mais affirme emporte tout
pour bien trier les déchets oui bien sûr
oui oui toujours le train pour aller à
paris deux allait investir
je ne jette jamais rien par terre fait
pas grand chose à part trier le
plastique carton tous à faire le tri
mais non je fais pas si vous voulez il
ya eu un bac de tri mais il n'est pas
très accessible en fait voilà il faut
plonger la main et je trouve pas ça très
hygiénique donc je le fais pas ton ordi
vos gestes pour l'environnement à vous
alors mes gestes pour l'environnement et
aversion alors déjà pour la prochain
pour un élu que je suis c'est
effectivement pour marmande de penser à
la qualité de vie à l'environnement de
ses habitants et ça vous dire ça
signifie c'est pas une mince mission
mais d'imaginer que dès qu'il ya
création d'un nouvel espace c'est le cas
de la zac de l'aérostat qui est un
nouveau quartier qui se construit à
trappes de penser son environnement son
environnement naturel
ces cheminements piétons et puis tout un
travail de la casse qui autour d'eux des
voies de circulations douces comme on
l'appelle
effectivement c'est déjà ça ensuite au
quotidien en père de famille puis en
citoyen je dirais c'est effectivement
penser à tous ces petits gestes du
quotidien qui sont pas évidents et pour
peut-être dire simplement que on apprend
peut-être un peu un peu tardivement
quelquefois que les boîtes à pizza ça
rentre pas dans les objets carton c'est
une petite chose comme ça donc ça ne
nécessite qu'une vraie médiation virée
entre le public et puis les gestes la
fin rappel permanent d'où cette semaine
de l'environnement attrape c'est en ce
moment la programmation complète sur le
site de la vie merci ni tom ailleurs dix
adjoints au maire en charge de ces
questions invité du journal en ce lundi
autre sujet culture la renaissance de la
fontaine de la tonne au château de
versailles ce matin l'un des plus forts
symboles du pouvoir du roi soleil a
repris vie il aura fallu deux ans de
travail et une centaine de personnes
reportage
moment d'émotion sur le regard des
artisans qui ont participé à ce chantier
unique mais aussi de quelques visiteurs
privilégiés
la mise en eau du bassin de latone ce
lundi matin le château de versailles
retrouve son visage d'antan celui
imaginé par le nôtre voici plus de trois
siècles dorure à leurs fins marbre de
carrare participe à la superbe de cette
pièce au moins aussi essentiel que la
galerie des glaces
nos visiteurs vont retrouver le bassin
de latone parce que ce bassin de latone
et est ici mais je crois qu'on ne
pouvait pas se faire une idée de sa
splendeur car il était singulièrement
détériorer il était à l'intérieur bien
sûr mais il était aussi à l'extérieur et
retrouver toute sa beauté retrouver la
couleur des marbres retrouver les l'état
sion des plombs et ben je crois que
c'est très important quand vous faites
une promenade à versailles que vous
arrivez en eau des terrasses que vous ne
savez pas que ce bassin est là et que
tout d'un coup vous le découvrez et si
en plus il est en haut je pense que là
c'est formidable
la donation à sa mort d'un riche mécène
suisse anonyme de 8 millions d'euros et
l'intervention de la fondation
philanthrôpia ont rendu possible cette
rénovation suivi en temps réel par
plusieurs millions de visiteurs depuis
2013 les matériaux d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui manipulés par les artisans
sur un chantier qu'il n'a pas été sans
difficultés
la principale difficulté de choc
chantier et nos métiers en général c'est
de voir dans les matériaux est ce que
les matériaux peuvent être encore
conservées avec toutes les techniques
modernes de consolidation que l'on peut
avoir aujourd'hui avec des résines avec
des cols avec vous alors est-ce que les
matériaux sans trop dégrader et il faut
les remplacer et pour les remplacer on a
besoin de savoir si on retrouve les
mêmes matériaux qu'à l'origine c'est un
problème qui s'est posé pour les marbres
et deux si on a encore des gens qui dans
les métiers qui ont présidé à la
construction savent encore pratiquer
encore ses savoir-faire ses techniques
ce soir le travail du marbre que ce soit
le travail de la dorure que ce soir le
travail de la fontainerie cette
rénovation ainsi permis la transmission
des savoir faire auprès d'une dizaine
d'apprentis
quant à la tonne mère d'apollon de diane
et maîtresse de jupiter elle ouvre
depuis la terrasse la grande perspective
dans le parc du château avec une fierté
et retrouver le festival de calme ses
films ses vedettes ses marchés son
équipe de radio sensations une nouvelle
fois nous retrouverons tout au long de
cette semaine sur place nicolas
kirillovitch il nous emmènera dans les
coulisses à la rencontre des yvelinois
qui ont fait le déplacement pour
travailler se faire connaître ou encore
tout simplement profiter des célèbres
soirées cannoises coup de projecteur en
ce lundi sur le marché du film est un
jeune réalisateur originaire de plaisir
douze mille c'est le nombre de
professionnels qui participent au marché
du film à cannes les professionnels du
cinéma du monde entier s'y retrouvent
pour acheter ou vendre des films quentin
dupuis est un jeune réalisateur de 24
ans originaire de plaisir il vient à
cannes pour la troisième année
consécutive et contrairement aux années
précédentes il n'a pas de fils m'a
montré mais des projets à financer
quentin dupuis est un passionné de
cinéma depuis qu'il est enfant un rêve
qu'il a concrétisée en faisant un bts
audiovisuel trois années de suite qu'il
vient au festival de cannes dans sa
mallette un ordinateur avec ses
dernières réalisations depuis son
dernier séjour sur la croisette quentin
n'a pas chômé il a réalisé un spot
contre la banalisation de l'homophobie
qu'est ce que c'est que ce petit shirt
15 kg moocher maintenant c'est plutôt
gai plusieurs pilotes de webséries pense
qu'il faut que je connaisse un peu mieux
le milieu avant 2 ou manager et
l'humilité
vous connaissez et un clip pour un
groupe de rock alternatif
cannes pour lui c'est the place to be
toute la ville vit cinéma pendant quinze
jours et c'est la beauté la beauté
inouïe du festival c'est à dire
qu'au-delà du strass et des paillettes
des tapis rouge va avant tout tous les
films qu'on va voir tout ce vent
s'achète se produit ici
enfin pas tous mais c'est un des plus
gros marchés de l'année un des plus gros
festivals de l'année dont il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de choses qui se font donc
c'est ça le le grand avantage
et du coup quand on enchaîne les
rencontres ce jour là il a rendez vous
au pavillon américain près du palais des
festivals d'année en année quentin le
cese d'étoffer son carnet d adresses ce
producteur réalisateur peter mousse au
lit par exemple est devenu l'un de ses
amis l'amérique un idéal pour quentin
c'est très business et très beau but
c'est très quel est ton projet comment
tu veux développer qu'est ce que tu veux
faire et voilà c'est ce que ce qui est
vraiment très peur ils sont très ouverts
quand il a mis fin l'an passé quentin
avait présenté un tact au short film
corner l'espace dédié aux courts
métrages l'histoire de deux survivants
face à une menace de zombies qui tourne
sous sol il a été séduit par ce film et
il a lancé un défi à quentin mais bien
et sinon
sortir l'ensa-t par les cas
bush et de mecs je lui ai dit est
quentin et si on en faisait un long
métrage
j'y vois le potentiel d'un alien quelque
chose dans l'esprit des premiers films
de ridley scott ou dabis de james
cameron quelque chose de vraiment bien
et d'intéressant mais sans besoin d'un
élan budget du coup je lui ai dit allez
faisons un film tu as un mois pour
l'écrire un scénario est né un road
movie en afrique avec deux personnages
qui tentent de survivre dans un monde
peuplé de zombies
quentin est donc maintenant à la
recherche de partenaires pour financer
son long métrage
vous serez sur un budget qui oscillerait
entre 500 mineurs millions $ pour
l'instant ce qui peut paraître énorme
mais ce qui est relativement à petit
pour le monde de cinéma ça reste un film
indépendant ça reste un petit budget et
voilà
on va voir ce qui va se passer montée de
monter ce projet cannes c'est la terre
des cinéphiles et une vitrine médiatique
quand en profite donc pour prendre des
contacts et essayer de convaincre des
producteurs et des distributeurs de
l'aider à boucler son budget et ainsi
réaliser son rêve faire son premier long
métrage
nicolas kirillovitch que l'on retrouvera
demain ils vous donnent également rendez
vous chaque jour 9h30 13h30 sur radio
sensations 98.4 pour encore plus de
festival de cannes la nuit européenne
des musées c'était ce samedi soir une
nouvelle fois c'était un succès 2
millions de visiteurs dans l'hexagone à
saint quentin en yvelines
le public a été convié autour du musée
de la ville à montigny-le-bretonneux
pour des animations dédiées aux odeurs
aux senteurs tour d'horizon sentir la
poussière les odeurs de transpiration de
moisissures de chaussettes sales de sang
séché pas très agréable et pourtant ces
odeurs font parfois partie de notre
quotidien au musée de la ville en lien
avec l'exposition tous dans le bain les
visiteurs pouvaient donc sentir et
ressentir
c'est l'occasion de mettre en valeur
leur faction c'est l'occasion de
travailler sur ce sens qui est
finalement assez ignorée c'est un sens
on est tous capables de détecter
pratiquement dix mille odeurs qu'on est
capable de reconnaître mais rarement de
nommer parce qu'en fait c'est une
langage qu'on n'apprend pas à l'école il
y avait aussi des odeurs agréables comme
un mode coco la crème solaire le
dentifrice ou des odeurs de notre
enfance
l'odeur traditionnel de savants de
marseille qui fait appel bien sûr à la
mémoire olfactive est ce qu on sait que
la mémoire olfactive remonte très loin
dans l'enfance elle repart très
rapidement vers l'enfance donc c'est
décidé ce sont aussi des odeurs de
confort de réconfort
on découvre des trucs sympas les odeurs
désagréables
un peu plus loin certains redessiner la
carte de saint-quentin-en-yvelines de
manière olfactives
un lieu une odeur associés participer à
la construction d'une nouvelle carte
graphique basée sur les odeurs et de de
perturber en quelque sorte l'histoire de
guérison par rapport à l'euro pour vos
villes et de prendre à la ville comme la
l'air vraiment la leur avec les odeurs
ce sera un homme c'est plutôt une
histoire de l'histoire de créer ensemble
une nouvelle ville une ville dans une
bulle de douceur sur le parvis du musée
fred le but leur faisait donc des bulles
géantes et ça que l'on soit petit ou
grand c'est toujours le même amusement
du sport à présent et en handball les
joueurs du paris saint-germain qui se
sont rendus à samedi au complexe pierre
de coubertin à montigny le bretonneux au
programme rencontre avec les jeunes de
la commune pour des séances de dédicaces
mais aussi pour du coaching le reportage
de michael et demi d'euros cette journée
restera sans doute gravée dans leur
mémoire celle dit trois joueurs du psg
handball zacharia n'diaye patrice
annonay et jeffrey m tima sont venus
animer un entraînement des moins de 15
ans de montigny le bretonneux
le club saint quentinois remporté un
concours organisé par le paris
saint-germain on a participé au
challenge voile comme pâques qu'organise
le psg l'année
c'est à dire que les clubs qui emmène
des gens voir les matches du psg en val
marque des points on s'est avéré être le
club qui a mené le plus de gens voir les
matchs du psg et donc on a gagné les
lots de ce fameux challenge reprend
pâques dans un entraînement animé comme
vous avez pu le voir par les joueurs du
psg sur le site du club en gagnant les
joueurs du psg ont profité de cette
session pour donner des conseils aux
jeunes
objectif les faire progresser pour
qu'ils deviennent professionnels dans
quelques années j'ai observé un petit
peu tous les derniers buts j'essaie de
leur donner quelques petits conseils
assez simple juste dans l'observation et
à une logique j'ai vu j'ai pu observer
qu'il a déjà les qualités assez
dynamique dans le but est à mais je
crois qu'il ya encore des petits travail
de sensations et de placements en fait
donc je sais ce que je disais si les
tirs à six mètres d'avancé pour essayer
de boucher langue mais pour le maximum
de place mais c'est bien après je peux
essayer de le faire mais à six mètres
faut avancer
après bah faut pas trop baisser quand on
fait l'arrêt une journée pleine
d'enseignements que les jeunes joueurs
de montigny le bretonneux n'oublieront
pas mais si c'est des grands joueurs
connus ça fait plaisir de les voir pire
on voit que
ce qu'on pourrait devenir plus tard tête
si on perd c'est bien ça m'a fait
plaisir
ils nous ont donné des conseils de ça
c'était savoir c'est déjà ma passion
mais là c'est là encore pis ça donne
envie ben d'être comme nous après je
pense que et vont tout faire bien pour
les bains pour aller au plus haut niveau
et peut-être s'il ya ba j'ai vu quelques
potentiels m je pense que si et qu il
continue à travailler je pense qu'il
peut arriver on dans le même bassin de
formation ou aller dans un grand club
montigny le bretonneux participera à
nouveau challenge
welcome pack la saison prochaine les
joueurs du psg pourrait donc foulé une
nouvelle fois le terrain du complexe
sportif pierre de coubertin est tout de
suite vous retrouver justement michael
demi d'euros pour le 7-8 sport très
bonne soirée sur notre antenne je vous
retrouve demain 18h pour un nouveau
journal
toujours directe
il